that's your service ready for the huddle
a waiting directed at your service yes
commander
loud and clear ready yeah right away
mm-hmm ready for action ready awaiting
orders awaiting direct interaction yes
commander well any and I'm here
commander you want something yes
what's going on what can I do for you
awaiting orders where to Darcy awaiting
orders
engaging I'm here commander reporting
mm-hmm what can I do for you ready
absitively commander ready foot back I'm
going I'm going you got it
we ride to victory okay
yes where to
yes commander
something on your mind never surrender
yeah what can I do
I'm goin ready
right away
ready
very well madam he understood ready for
action I'm here cool commander you need
me ready order what is that II orders
got me there awaiting directive I'm here
to sir locked and loaded commander I'm
here farm ative you need me
waiting directive ready what is it at
the ready you want something
leo
any perfect awaiting orders I'm here
reporting I'm here top
yes
ready all right
I'm honey
you're so you need me yes commander
don't do it I'm here
yes commander yeah
ready hit me what's going on awaiting
orders you rang a wee thing order ready
for battle ready commander ready
commander what can I do for you
what do you need locked and loaded
ready for action
go ahead commander
awaiting orders
awaiting correct where to what's going
on
reporting
I'm
ready for service
don't do it
you rang where to what can I do for you
awaiting orders waiting directive
I'm here to say so a horse
I'm here to manor the weight indirectly
yes what can I do for you certain ready
where do
locked and loaded I'm here
I'm here I'll take care of it a fraction
do
loud every layer
ready for act
that's your service
sooo
ready
hit men at the ready
and ready
ready for action you need me let's do
this awaiting directive hi guys
reporting
affirmative
awaiting orders
understood at your service what is it no
problem do it for you nothing to it
go ahead waiting for action
but we can direct you
that's your service you rang what can I
do for you you can watch this yeah yes
commander commander
what do you need ready for a bet talk to
me commander yes is that it awaiting
orders ready he'll bat
what is it
I'm here dandy right away awaiting
director ready to roll out
I'm here proceeding I'm here commander
right away
you need me you need me yes commander it
men ready to sue
we'll see
ready for them
come on your mind that's your sir
yeah yes commander yes
go ahead what I do let's do this
awaiting orders at four ready ready
commander ready talk to me for you
commander
I'm on it
we're at it I will oblige
reporter
ours ready for us ready demander i'm
here at the ready one you need me
Oh
where to
yes I'm going where to ready for action
you want something
don't omit ready I'm here to sir
reporting waiting director waters